übrigens werde ich euch das ganze gleich
an diesem shafir zeigen
hallo ich in meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung und zwar von dem digitalen
slot für die 1.4 punkt 7
diese mod fügt einige interessante dinge
hinzu und zwar könnt ihr euch einen hund
ja sonst oder ein wolf wolf heißer und
ich könnt ihr euch normalerweise ja
immer themen dieser dir diese
modifikation fliegt aber diese dinge
hier noch hinzu die findet ihr unter
food stoffs mit denen ihr das ganze noch
ein bisschen besser gestalten könnt und
naja ich zeige euch erst mal ganz kurz
davor habe ich doch schon getestet
man kann die hunde übrigens die sind
nach jetzt so stark mit magath töten
egal ich kommt es nun zum motto bot hier
haben wir den trainings treating crafted
man sich mit string band oder also eine
seite ein knochen dann allerdings hier
schießpulver schwarz weiß nicht dran
drei reihen zucker und dann drei rhein
wied also weizen bekommt mein training
street mit diesem training street kann
man die hunde nachher aufwerten ich
werde das gleich alles zeigen
dann gibt es ein super trieb weil dieser
training street der recht nicht für alle
level sondern nur bis level 30 20 über
zehn irgendwie so danach muss man den
super trittin kraft hat man mit fünf
training street und einem goldenen apfel
also schon sehr heftig man geht es dem
master treat dafür braucht man fünf
super treat wird die man allgemein erst
mal die goldenen äpfel braucht und noch
einen diamanten dann kann die master
täter sitzen nicht im rating note dann
nimmt man fünf wochen im master treat
und ein santo mein gott da kriegt man
einen tweet
da gibt es ein problem kann man einfach
wegwerfen wie der name schon sagt wer
ein bisschen englisch kann werfen
beinknochen werfen knochen wegwerfen
hund passt irgendwie zusammen da braucht
man einfach nur 545 knochen und ein
slime ball in die mitte danach meint
robert gibbs koloss schied koller shears
da braucht man einfach vier von diesen
knochen und eine schere aber diesen
eigentlich nicht so wichtig deswegen
stellt die nicht vorsieht ist es nicht
grundlegend für diese modifikation da
gibt es den breeding bauen
das ist ein knochen
ja ist halt auch da mit dem kann man die
sachen kann man die die hundehaltern und
so weiter also man macht das aus einem
master treat stage schicken guckt fisch
und coupon job und dann gibt's kommenden
tag und das ist auch ganz witzig damit
kann dem hund zu rumkommandieren dafür
braucht man viel gold in einen bogen
ich zeige euch das mal ganz kurz an
einem bus der hund entdeckt man wasser
mussten spawn übrigens werde ich euch
das ganze gleich an diesem shafir zeigen
dass mein hund taste hat ach nee ja okay
gut was machen sie denn hier also was
macht ihr wenn ihr nun zählt erstmal mit
dem bauern hin höhe zu sammeln und der
folgt uns jetzt auf schritt und tritt
und der bleibt irgendwie geradestehen
verdammter penner so warte aber jetzt
können wir erstmal einen trading street
nehmen achtet man auch sein wenn sich
bitte an achtet auf sein bändchen so es
wird blaue das heißt er gehorchte und
jetzt können wir ein stick neben rechts
auf den drauf machen und wir sind hier
menü wir können jetzt erstmal benennen
ich nenne diesen hund konny reimann paar
von euch wissen was das heißt
so jetzt können wir hier wir haben jetzt
points to spend 15
da können wir jetzt gar doch hier so
paar punkte geben dann gehen die punkte
herunter und jetzt war es auch schon
er kann einfach jetzt drücken wir
draußen hat die id 2 der de um 22 heißt
konny reimann steht die oben alles
drüber und jetzt könnt ihr auf jeden
fall die trainings treats nehmen dann
steht ein level up im chat das können
jetzt so lange machen bis das gehalts
stoppt so mehr geht nicht
und jetzt müssen wir die super tweets
nehmen da machen wir damit jetzt immer
drauf
so jetzt können einfach im chat zur
buchstaben schreiben haar und wenn jetzt
rächt sich dass man seht ihr da kommt
nicht mehr level up das funktioniert die
mir hier das funktioniert wieder
aber so da müssen wir die master chiefs
nehmen die nehmen wir jetzt dann kriegt
er halt noch mehr punkte für wieder ein
chat in buchstaben schreiben kommt geht
es mir hör nehmen jetzt die
deutschschweiz haben jetzt hier
hallo wie geht das nicht man muss
erstmal hier nicht machen
ich war noch mal kurz von vorne wenn man
ist so denen das alles von hier und
jetzt die dire straits als funktioniert
auch mit sekt aufmachen sie wie popstars
-band 57 jetzt können wir hier so ein
bisschen hochpumpen hierzu verschiedene
dinge die man hier so auswählen kann ich
kann die hand dort machen in jene punkte
runter bleibt aber so verschiedene dinge
halt und der hunde segment stark jetzt
können wir uns eigentlich relativ
unnötig macht rechtsgeschäfte weg der
hund läuft ein holt sich der frauen
kommt zurück und gibt es euch wieder
allerdings ist das jetzt so komisch
angelegt und können sich wieder
wegschmeißen
also nur eine spielerei bekommen jetzt
mal zu mit den kommenden tag sachen und
zwar zu diesem scharf dass jetzt
umbringen werden und zwar konny reimann
konnte kurz mit hier kommt ihr durch
schön jetzt können einfach auf das
schafft dieses kommende tags drauf
machen da kommt das einem schneeball
raus und dann greift er das an so und
mädchen der hund ist so immens stark der
bringt das schaf wirklich zum brennen
und es ist direkt tot ins team
da gibts noch drei von so anderen
comment sachen zwar kommentiert da kam
einfach machen und setzt sie sich in
konstant dann steht er wieder so kann
man ihm zeit zu machen erhöht
und dann gibt's kommen check up was das
genau bedeutet weiß ich nicht das ist
wohl irgendwie dass der typ du weg
laufen darf oder nicht hinterherlaufen
muss also irgendwie so um den dreh
es war nicht allzu wichtig also eine
relativ kurze modifikation ihr wolltet
ihr dass ich umfangreichere mods
vorstelle wo bist du denn ich habe
nichts zu tun mit dem
na ja da kann ich euch jetzt mal ganz
kurz zeigen
die hab ich übrigens nicht so genannten
das war schon von anfang an so wie
schlagfertig dieser runde sind weil ich
mir nicht in dem treff deswegen greifen
sie nicht zurück an
aber das ist immens trasse für die
aushalten übrigens habe ich meinen hund
jetzt nicht auf komplettes level ebene
höhe gebracht dafür 1000 jahre lang
hätte draufklicken müssen mit
rechtsklick wenn ihr den auf einer ganz
hohen ebene hat dann kommt so ein
komisches ender melden
rings um den hier rum also das hat mein
hund namens der hatte das halt schon
vorher also ich hab den so hoch dreht
und ihr seht schon der ist relativ stark
also ich kann ja die ganze zeit darauf
um klopfen ihr seht schon dass wenn ihr
den erst mal so hoch trainiert habt
euren hunde das wird jahre mal da hinten
ist vermehrt euch mal typisch alter ist
es doch wieso habe ich auf einmal die
vermehrt sich am 3 schlagt ihn hatte
vorhin war es so ich habe ihn geschlagen
weil man auf schade
naja egal ich schlage ihn und er kriegt
schaden nach ok cool hier zählt die
modifikation hat noch ein paar fehler
aber ich hoffe erstmal kommt euch das
alles ein bisschen näher bringen wenn
ihr interessant interessiert seid
anderen hunde züchtung e10 sicher auf
einmal konny reimann hat sich auch schon
vermehrt das geht auch naja egal also
paar bugs und wirklich noch enthalten
aber auf jeden fall relativ interessante
modifikation die pforten sich hier oben
alter ich bin total verwirrt gerade naja
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
wenn es euch gefällt könnt ihr einfach
in die kommentare schreiben was sie gut
findet oder eventuell eine nächste
modifikation nicht vorstellen soll
und ihr könnt ja auch in die kommentare
schreiben allgemein wie euch solche
modifikationen gefallen oder ob ihr
lieber so sinnlose modifikation wollt
ihr super sachen hinzufügen wenn ich gar
nicht auch dann würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr das lied bewertet also schaffen
wir irgendwie 1000mikes oder so dass
wäsche und haben angst ich komme damit
einer genau so aus wie ich genau dass
ich freunde bis jetzt beim nächsten mal
tschüss